hi everyone this is esthie kelman of
telugu university
i'm here to present the paper terence of
kkl
fleetwood and telegram via random
restriction and logs of olivine quality
this is joint work with subash fought
guy kendall
domingue and my advisor municipal thank
you for joining us
let me start with some basics of boolean
functions over the binary hypercube
so what is the n-dimensional binary
hypercube
this is a graph constitutes of two to n
nodes each one is an n-tuple
of zero and ones example for n equal
three
for every two nodes they differ in
exactly one coordinate we have an edge
between them
that's our edges
a boolean function is a function of any
input bit and one
output bit you can think about the
inputs as nodes in the n-dimensional
binary hypercube
and the output two values such as minus
one
one zero and one or just two colors
so function a boolean function is a two
coloring of
the binary hypercube
as you can see in the example you can
see that there
are two different types of uh
edges there are the monochromatic edges
and the others which are
what's called sensitive edges because
they
they are sensitive to the value of the
function
moving on the this edge changes the
the value of the function we can strict
our
view to some specific direction let's
say direction i
and ask how many edges in this direction
are sensitive and the fraction of those
edges
called the influence of the bit i
of the variable i and formally this is
the probability
of the uniformly random input that
flipping the its variable changes the
output
when we have the influence of all the
input bits we can sum up all of them
together to get the total influence
you see that the total influence
actually takes into account
all the sensitive edges in all
directions
and therefore it's equal to the number
of sensitive edges in the entire cube
normalized by two to the n minus one
that's why it's also called the average
sensitivity
later we'll see that it's also the
average
degree
the key question in the area of boolean
functions
ask what can we say about the structure
of functions
let's say if we know something about the
total influence or about the influences
some classic results related to this
such as kkl and others let us see them
the kkl theorem from
88 said that
every boolean function as a non-trivial
influence for some variable
there is at least one variable with
significant
individual influence
what's sent behind this theorem is that
there is a variable which its influence
is at least into minus the total
influence
this means that as long as the
total influence is small there is a
variable with
large individual influence
without quantitative say that
every boolean function essentially
depends on due to the total influence
many variables
and what stands behind this is uh
generalizations
of the kkl it says that
most of the rate of the function is on
variables for which this
is their individual influence is at
least two to minus the total influence
so the k can say that there is at least
one variable such
like that and we could say that most of
the rate is on variables of this type
another classic results related to this
is the target inequality
this inequality say that the target sum
which we have in the
right hand side is at least the variance
of the function f
if the function is balanced you can
think about the variance as constant
the tang and sun each summoner
somehow capture the variance in the
direction i
and the first purpose of this
inequality was a sharpen and
generalization of the kkk and then
and later it became a central tool in
theoretical computer science
and also it plays a role in
probability theory such as in
percolation
and random matrices
what's common for all these three terms
in their original proofs there is a key
technique they all
use this is the hyper contractive
inequality
the idea behind the hyper-contractive
inequality is
that applying the noise on the function
smoothes the function and that's how it
reduce norms
in this original proofs and also in many
other proofs in
the area of brain functions
we use a
corollary of this hyper-contractive
inequality
which is noise operator
free and instead gives a lower
bound on the maximal degree
let us see that
for this we need some more basics of the
boolean functions analysis for the next
fact about
functions over the binary hypercube is
that every function
has a unique representation which calls
the fourier representation
and the summation over subset of
variables for every subset as
f at s times chi s of x
for pi x is the character function of
s which equals minus one if the
number of ones in the very in the set
s is odd and otherwise it's one
and f s is f s
is a real number which called the
fourier coefficient of
f now we can define the degree of a
function intuitively
this is the maximal size of
of a character of a set of a character
for which the fourier coefficient is not
zero
the hyper contractility say that the
degree is
at least the log of the ratio between
two nodes four and norm three halves
these three halves is flexible
you can choose any constant number
between one and two
and this inequality
considered somehow a bit mystery
and there have been uh
efforts recently to prove kkl theorems
and other terms
without using the hyper contractivity
and there are some works about it and
what we do
we give a new unified approach to all
these
three theorems to prove the
kcal free goods and targets inequality
without using the hypercontractivity
what we do instead
we use log sobolev inequality instead of
the
hyper-contractivity and random
restriction in a very in a certain way
in order to analyze functions you want
somehow
to simplify them and therefore it would
be easier to
uh to analyze them for doing random
restriction
make the function
smaller we take only a sub cube of of
all the cube and restrict our view to e
sometimes the function there is much
simpler
our mission is to make it
as simpler as all the rate is on
the first fourier level and then we can
say this is
just a dictatorship we can do it exactly
like this and here we need
for example the uh to use
the hyper contractivity but we don't
know
exactly what the degree is we know that
we uh we succeed to take a lot of the
fourier mass and put it to the first
fourier level
but we don't know what the exact degree
is
and here the logs over of inequality
comes to help us
in this talk will not grow deeply in it
but
let us see some version of it
so we have the hyper contractivity as we
said
and now let us define another property
of
boolean functions we can look at the
set of the numbers for your coefficient
squared
and this is a set of non-negative
numbers
you can think about them that they are
sum up to one
and if not you can normalize it it's not
really change the
parameters and the behavior of the
function
and now once we have a bunch of
non-negative numbers that sum up to one
we can look at them as a probability
distribution
we call this distribution the
fourier distribution when we choose
every subset of
n with probability f at s
squared
now we can intuitively define the
average degree
to be the average of the character
size over there
according to the fourier distribution
some corollary some version of the log
support of inequality
say that the average degree is at least
log the ratio of the norms point one
this is very similar to the hyper
contractivity
you can see that this is a bit stronger
since
the maximum degree is always
larger than the second degree
and even the right hand side is always
larger in the log circle level then in
the hyper contractivity
even though in the hyper contractivity
that three halves is not
not necessarily be this constant you can
put any constant between one and two
um but not exactly one
what we have in the log server it's much
better than hyper contractivity is that
we can use the expected degree
as an additive parameter what i mean
is that you can take a function a
boolean function and
take it's for your presentation for
example position it to
uh destroying destroying set of
uh characters now you can analyze each
set each one of these two functions
separately and using
their expected degree and when you
combine them together back
you get that next new expected degree is
expectation
or the average of those two expected
degrees
and this property we don't have with the
ipo contractivity where
use the maximal degree and then each
combination we do
it's always might be that the maximal
degree
is as the maximal of all the functions
but you can see that since the october
is
stronger than the hyper contractivity
it's not so
um exciting to
just replace the log survey with the
hyper contractivity
but what's so interesting in our in this
result is that
we have a new approach a new way and new
techniques how to use the random
restriction
in a very certain way which we'll see
later
and also to have
a unified proof that a unified approach
could prove
uh both three groups and paragons in
quality
this is not so trivial
so just to mention there are other
proofs
that are hyper contractivity free
for example we have the phallic and some
modern skill they
used log support of inequality they
proved kkl and triggered quanta
but their approach doesn't seem to be
extendable
to uh to prove their target inequality
another recent proof by language they
proved the targets
inequality and also for some
other uh conjunctions with paragraph
and they used um a very different
method using photography calculus
and the analysis of jump forces
so after this opening what are we going
to see in this talk so let us build
the random switch and see exactly how we
want to use it
we'll see what version of the logo of
inequality
we use in this talk i'm going to tell
you we're going
just to use the edges of parametric
inequality which is
a simple corollary of the logs of 11 and
then we'll see the proof idea of the kkn
term and the way you will do it is to
prove the cake alteram with some
simplifying assumptions
and for sure in the paper you can see
how to get rid of these assumptions and
how to prove also their free goods and
targets inequality so let us start with
random restrictions
so what is random restriction we have a
function with an
input variables and two bits and we want
to fix
uh some set of variables
j to be the alive variables
to stay alive
and we use uh we choose this
j randomly as each variable
would stay alive with probability mu for
some new that you will choose
later what are you going to do with
the rest of variables
we want to fix them we choose
some z to be the assignment a constant
assignment for
the rest of the variable the n minus j
and this we also want to be randomized
so we choose each one of them to be zero
or one
randomly with probability of for each
what we end up is a function which we
denote
f j z which is a function of
the input variables in the set of j
to the reals and the values of this
function
for each input on the like variables
the value of the function is the f
on the node z
comma y
so this is just we just get
focused in a sub cube defined by
z and that's why we
hope this will be a simpler
function easier to analyze so this
function
is a random function we can ask some
questions about
the random behavior of it for example
even the set of the variables on it
its input is random so we can ask how
many variables
stayed aligned and this is
pretty easy we choose each variable
independently
it's probability nu so we have mu times
n many variables
in the expected case we can even ask
more than that for every character how
many variables stayed aligned
in this character and same calculation
gives
us that this is mu times the size of the
set
s and from here you can see that if we
want
a character of size s to
go all the way down to the first fourier
level we need mu to be one over the size
of
s let us see how we use it
we can ask more questions what is the
expected rate on level k for example
level k is just the four year rate on
all the characters of size k
and you can ask how it is
expectedly on j and z and with some
calculation we get
that uh the inner expectation
is the rate on all characters for which
the
their intersection with j is exactly k
and
some arithmetic tricks we need we
get to the summation over all characters
for their for mass
times the probability of the character
to intersect j
with exactly k variables let's see some
example
let's think about an homogeneous
function of degree exactly d
this means that all its characters with
non-zero fourier coefficient
are of size d and let us choose mu
to be one over d now the
probability for each character
to intersect j with exactly one variable
is constant
and that's why we get that the
expected mass
on the first fourier level on
all their restricted functions is
constant
let us generalize it a little bit and
think about
functions of degree approximately
roughly d
this means that we have a constant
weight on characters of size roughly d
i mean between half d and 2d
on this function the randomness friction
with
mu equals 1 over d is
is the same we have we again have
a constant weight for each character of
this side roughly d
we have a constant probability
to as only one exactly one variable
stayed alive
and therefore expectedly we have
constant rate
on the first four year level
so now it means that
there exists some j for which
the fourier coefficient of the first
fourier level expected beyonce
is constant let us fix this j
and from now on we stick to this j
now let me do a strong assumption just
to get a proof idea
and we assume that it's not only
expectedly on that
but for every z we have exactly
one is it's not
so much strong assumption if we
assume that it's not only constant but
it's exactly one then it's also one for
every z
because it can't be louder than one
but now once we have a boolean function
and we know that
all of its fourier mass is on the first
fourier level
we now know exactly how its structure
looked like there is only two options
it's either a dictatorship or minus
dictatorship
this means that each one of this z
choose some variable to be its
dictatorship
f j z is a dictatorship x j or minus x j
this doesn't really matter now let's go
with this
remember that for every z f j z
is a dictatorship x j that means that z
chooses
j to be its dictatorship
and now we can associate
this z with the x j and partition
all the cube the
sets in the cube according to the
variable they choose to be their
dictatorship
normally we define aj the set a j
to b all the z such
that f j z is x j
or minus x j all this is that
chooses j to be the radical
we can ask what is the density
of this set a j
a k they choose x k
or a l a choose itself
and we claim that the density of aj
is exactly the influence of the variable
j
on the function f
and you can see it for every
z in aj we know that z choose x j to be
its dictatorship this mean that xj is
influential in this input
in every input that
is that its prefix is dead
and on the other side for every z that
is not in
mj if there is nothing fragile
if that is belongs to a l then
it has only one dictatorship which is
its l
therefore x j is not influential
so you can see that the density of aj is
exactly the influence
of a of the j variable
when the density is the probability that
z is
in aj this equals
exactly to the probability of a random
input that
flipping the js variable change the
output
and now let's recall
that we want to prove the kkkl term
which says that
there is a variable with i
influence so if all the influences are
small
we if there is a variable with i
influence we are done so let us assume
that all influences are small
let us let's say smaller than one over
square root n
and now what we have to do is to find
that that the
total influence is large this means that
we need to find
a lot of sensitive edges so let us see
where are the sensitive edges
hide and
here out there we look at an edge
between
two different groups between
aj and al for example this
is sensitive edge why because it's going
from a dictatorship xj to dictatorship
excel
and therefore if xj and xl sets to
zero one or one zero going on this
edge would change the value of
the function so at least half of the
edges that are in between
two uh groups two partitions
two parts are sensitive
so we want to count them and see that
there are
many for this we need
the uh logs of our inequality
let us see what we know about the logs
of volume inquiry
so there is a definition of something
that's called the entropy
of the values of f squared will not
go into it i just don't know why it's
called entropy because this is
in the information theory called
information left
and then the theorem say that the total
influence is larger than
half the entropy the total influence is
also the expected degree that's how it's
related to the
um previous corollary showed
and let us see the corollary which
called the standard edges of aromatic
inequality which we really need
this said that the edge boundary
of a set of a set a
you can see that the edge boundary delta
a is all the edges that are going from
inside
a to outside a
the size of it is at least the size of
the set
a times log one over the density of a
and the way to to get this quarterly
formula of inequality is to
define some function f to be
the indicator function of the set a
and then just
substitute it in the in this version of
the log sofa level we get
the standard edge is a theoretic in
quality
and this is what's important for us to
say at the boundary
is at least the size of a times log 1
over the density of a letter d
so we've seen the random restriction we
took the
the weight from larger degrees to the
first fourier level
we did the partition and well
now we want to use the log support of
inequality in order to prove kkkl
theorem
so we're not going to prove exactly the
kql theorem and we'll do it with some
simplifying assumptions
uh but we'll see the proof idea
so just a reminder what is a kkl theorem
it says that there is
a variable with significant influence
log n over n
and the way to prove it is let us assume
that
all variables as small influences
we use random restriction to show all
ai's are small
and then let us use logs overlap to that
the total influence
is large so we need two things
in our mind and then we can
find the influential edges so
the first one is the edges of parametric
inequality
that says that the edge boundary is at
least the size of the set log one over
its density and the other thing is that
we showed our uh random restriction and
partition
so that mu a j as the influences and we
assume all of them
smaller than 1 over square root n
so now once we say that all of this
um sets are small
and we need we have the uh
the edges that are going in between sets
and say that there are
sensitive edges there are infrared
challenges
we see that for every subset
every small set there is a large edge
boundary how
large the number of
edges going from inside to outside it is
at least the number of
of nodes inside times half log n
okay we put here in the edge
interferometry the our assumption that
mu a
j is smaller than one over square root n
so i omit here
some constants but that's fine
now what we have to do just to count all
the edges in between is
to sum up the edges of parametric
inequality for
all the sets
so we sum up it and we get that the
number of sensitive edges is
at least log n times the summation over
all sets which cover all the cube
and therefore this is 2 to the n times
log n
again here we omit some two constant
because we
count every edge twice
that's fine just constant two now
now we can normalize both sides by two
to the n and we get the average
sensitivity
is at least slogan the very sensitivity
is total influence
from this we get that the total there is
some variability
which is influences at least the total
influence over and
therefore logan over n and we are done
so let's see what we have seen
we've seen hyper conductivity free proof
for the kkl under some simplifying
assumptions we did random restrictions
to put to push the fourier energy to the
first fourier level we map restrictions
to dictatorship
variables and that's how we shorted
these partitions are small and
then we found a nice amount of hidden
sensitive edges
in case where all influences are small
this show that the total influence is
louder than again and
then trivially we have an influence with
logan over n
in the paper you first you
can find uh the entire po for the kkl
and get rid of the cheating assumptions
but
you would also find proofs
for the frequent from the theorem and
targeting quality using
same techniques let us talk a bit about
open questions so
there are new techniques here then we
want to use them
to prove other statements in boolean
functions and discover
new things so there are some terms by
berlin that is
uh might be applied there maybe you can
prove the fourier entropy influence
conjecture using these techniques
and also uncertainty and certainly
theorems
maybe logs overlap can be looked as
uncertainty theorem
and
it's a bit connected to the free entropy
influence conjecture
you can look at it and see that it says
that the total influence expected degree
plus
the shannon entropy of the values is
larger than
n and there is another uncertainty
principle by
going to moles that say that the for
entropy
plus the value of entropy is larger than
n
so maybe using this with our techniques
might lead to the free entropy influence
contracture
and that's all thank you for listening